SPEAKER: So you guys have
heard the word "Dart Dev
Compiler," or DDC.
What is it?
We talked about it a
little bit last year,
at last year's summit.
It is a new Dart to
JavaScript compiler.
It is not intended
to replace Dart2JS,
but to be a complement to it.
DDC is very much
focused on development
on [INAUDIBLE] browsers.
And in fact, one of
the first questions
we asked when we started
DDC is, what would it
take to provide a Dartium-like
experience in regular Chrome?
What would it take
to let developers
have that same sort
of fast iteration
experience on regular Chrome?
And how can they take
advantage, for example,
of the browser
developer tools the way
we've added hooks into Dartium?
We're also very much
interested in providing
a very strong error checking
experience as part of DDC.
Leif talked about this quite
a bit in the last talk.
Strong Mode and DDC
are very integrated
to provide a nice,
static plus runtime
error checking experience.
It's very important when
you're developing code.
We also want to
support other browsers.
That's what we can
do by compiling
to JavaScript quickly.
And we have support for
things like Source Maps.
But we also want to
make it possible to drop
into JavaScript and see
readable, developable
JavaScript for people who
need to go down to that level.
And then finally, a theme
I'll hit on a little bit
later is we also want to make
it very easy to integrate
into any kind of
standard build tool,
whether it be our own
internal tools at Google
or any other tools.
And I'll have a demo that
talks a little bit about that.
Development's been
our main theme.
But kind of a secondary
theme that will come through
is that DDC is a platform for
JavaScript interoperability.
This dovetails actually
quite a bit with our goals
for development.
We want to be able to generate
readable JavaScript code.
And what we really try
to do as much as possible
is just target idiomatic
ECMAScript 6 code.
So Dart classes map
to JavaScript classes,
Dart methods map to
JavaScript methods,
properties to properties,
getters and setters
to getters and setters
with minimal name mangling.
Another part of this is
also to actually take
advantage of JavaScript
module frameworks,
so to map Dart modules
into standard JavaScript
modules such as Node or AND
or the forthcoming ES6 module
system and play well with those.
Leif talked a little
bit about soundness.
And soundness ties
in a lot to DDC.
And I want talk a little bit
about that before I go on.
Standard Dart is intentionally
unsound by design.
And this is a bit of a pop
quiz to see if you were paying
attention to Leif's talk.
If I have a list of numbers and
I add the first two elements
together, what can happen?
Anybody, it's a pop quiz.
AUDIENCE: Anything.
AUDIENCE: Don't know.
SPEAKER: Absolutely
anything is probably right.
A developer would
reasonably think, OK, well
it could throw a null
pointer exception.
List could be null.
That's true.
It could throw an array
out of bounds exception.
The list might not
have two elements.
You kind of think or hope
that most of the time,
it would print a number.
But it could be anything.
This is legal Dart code.
And interestingly,
you won't get,
in standard Dart, any static
errors or runtime failures,
even if you're
running in check mode.
You can pass in strings.
You can even pass in cats,
as you saw, or anything else.
So that makes it challenging.
There's an interesting
implication
to this for those of
us who are actually
developing tools or
writing compilers,
or even for developers
who are trying
to reason about the code.
And that's that we can't
really use those static type
annotations, or we
couldn't before.
The static type of that
expression adding the two lists
is num.
But the compiler can't
assume that that's
a numeric operation.
We can't just generate
standard JavaScript plus if we
are generating code from that.
It could be anything.
Dart has operator overloading.
So even though it's plus
and would work for string,
it wouldn't work for cat.
I'm not sure exactly how
you would add two cats,
but those things can
happen, I suppose.
So what many people are a
little bit surprised about
is that Dart2JS doesn't
really use static types
to generate code.
It actually drops
the type information
and recovers it all
in a more sound way.
But it's not using
the static types
that you, as a
programmer, write.
This isn't actually
that unusual.
In fact, pretty much
every common typed
JavaScript variant, and
there's a bunch of them
now, are also unsound.
So here's effectively the
same example in TypeScript,
no static errors or warnings.
Prints hello world.
I have a list of
numbers here at the top.
I can just populate
that with strings.
I'm not going to get an error
or warning in TypeScript.
Of course, in TypeScript,
code generation
is just type erasure.
So you have that number
annotation there.
All we have to do
is get rid of it.
That's fine.
TypeScript types by design
aren't intended for compilers
to use.
I don't think any
tools actually try
to use them to do
optimization, for example.
Dart is not JavaScript.
That's a good thing.
I think you guys wouldn't
be here if it was.
But we often get this
question about compilation.
So let's take this
fragment of Dart code here.
Why can't we just translate
that to the same JavaScript?
That fragment is conveniently
legal JavaScript and Dart.
Why is that different?
Well, the semantics
are different.
And I hope you'll agree with
me that this is a good thing.
And just to go into
detail a little bit
here, if a doesn't happen to
have a bar field here, in Dart,
you're just going
to get an error.
In JavaScript, well,
we'll just throw undefined
and keep trucking along.
And who knows what's
going to happen, right?
Same thing with methods.
If we pass in too few or too
many in Dart, you get an error.
In JavaScript, they
just figure out some way
to keep trucking along.
So again, we think this is a
really good thing about Dart.
We certainly don't
want to change that.
Dart has fail-fast semantics.
You don't want to
just keep trucking.
If you're writing
serious applications,
we believe undefined
behavior is bad.
And you want, as a developer,
to know about these errors
as soon as possible.
And even if you
ship the code out,
you don't really want
undefined behavior
happening in your applications.
This does come at
a cost, though.
So if you take that bit
of Dart, what Dart2JS
does in the general
case is to generate
something that looks like this.
And these interceptor
objects are basically
what's doing the
dispatch in Dart2JS
to make sure the
right things happen.
So if you look at
generated code,
sometimes you might
see these things.
Now, Dart2JS is an aggressive,
whole program optimizing
compiler.
And a lot of times,
it's able to get rid
of a lot of this overhead.
But what you get at the end
might be pretty efficient,
but might not look a lot
like what you started with.
And it takes quite a
bit of time to do that.
So DDC is very much
tied to strong mode
to be able to generate
reasonably nice code very
quickly.
And we take
advantage of the fact
that we can now trust with
strong mode the type checks.
So if this little
snippet of code
here now type checks in
strong mode and a and b
are statically typed,
then we, at compile time,
know that a.bar can't throw
a no such method exception,
and b.foo can't either.
And that means that we can
actually generate more or less
the same JavaScript code.
So the JavaScript you get
out looks a lot like the Dart
that you get in.
So safety is basically-- you
get a lot of the same safety
properties.
But most of them are
actually enforced statically.
As Leif said, not all of
them, but most of them
are actually
enforced statically.
And DDC can generate code
that takes advantage of that.
Implication, of course, is
that DDC requires strong mode,
but that's what you're getting
out of it, just to be clear.
So type checking is one
aspect of modularity.
We're rethinking a lot of the
build system here with DDC.
We can modularly
type check things.
That means that we can do
the type checking locally
on a module without
having the entire program.
If the module type checks, we
can do modular type-driven code
generation.
We don't need the whole program.
We can use the types there
to generate nice code.
That lets us plug into
modular build systems,
whether you're old school
and like to use make files,
or you want to use something
as advanced as Bazel, which
is Google's build
system, and there'll
be a talk on that
tomorrow, and I'll talk
a little bit about that later.
You can also generate modules,
JavaScript modules for example,
and play nicely with deployment
tools that are out there,
like Webpack.
We just generate modules.
Webpack can consume them.
So I'll show you the demo.
And this is going to be based
on the Captain's Log app
from yesterday's
code lab using DDC.
Who did that code lab, just
a show of hands quickly?
Yeah, several of you
managed to do that.
Great.
Yesterday's code lab was
showing DDC working with Bazel,
which is our new build system.
And you'll learn more
about that tomorrow.
And I'll talk a little
about that later.
But I have a
different variant here
that works with Node
modules and Webpack,
just to show you the
flexibility in the system.
So what we're going
to do with DDC
is that we're going
to take this app,
and we're going to compile
it down to different modules.
And we just basically do this at
a package granularity in Dart.
So you'll see essentially
five different modules
in the system.
The SDK, package.js,
which we're going
to use to talk to a WYSIWYG
editor called quilljs.
Those of you who
actually ran the code lab
would have seen it.
And Jacob will talk a little bit
about that in about 20 minutes.
Package.funk, which has some
nice function utilities.
The package that's part of the
app itself, the Captain's Log.
And then, a main driver app
to build it all together.
There's kind of a
make-based build.
I should say, I found
out I had to give a demo.
Well, actually, I
wanted to give a demo.
I wanted to do something cool.
Someone told me about Webpack.
I never used Webpack before.
And so this actually came
together pretty quickly.
I ran Webpack for
the first time,
and then got something
more or less running
in about five or six hours.
But it's glued
together with make
to kind of drive
the Dart building
and Webpack to do the
bundling and serving.
And let's take a look.
So first of all, this is a make
file that basically shows you
how you can invoke DDC.
Unlike Dart2JS, it's not
a whole program compiler.
I don't know how many of you
are familiar with make files,
but they're very simple.
Target on the left,
sources on the right.
If js.dart changes, we
invoke DDC to produce js.js.
Similarly with the funk package.
Captain's Log is a little
bit more interesting.
We take two Dart files,
and we take summaries,
and we invoke DDC.
These summaries
basically just mean
that Captain's Log depends
on these modules up there.
The summary is just an
API level summarization
of those libraries.
So if you're editing
something up here
and the APIs didn't change,
the build short circuits.
You don't have to
build anything else.
And then, finally, the
main.js at the bottom,
which ties it all together.
And also takes in summaries.
So again, if you're
editing Captain's Log,
you don't affect the API,
main won't get built.
So I'm lying a little bit.
I actually ended up wrapping
this up in a Dart Watcher thing
because I didn't
want to type make.
And you can see it's kind of
running in the background,
looking for things, and just
running the minimal build step.
In most cases, I'm going to
be editing just this Captain's
Log.
And it will build
the minimal thing.
I have Webpack
sitting on the side
listening to changes in
the produced JavaScript
and serving it up.
So let's actually see.
So DDC and Webpack
don't actually
know anything about each other.
But they talk the
same module format.
So it actually was surprisingly
straightforward to glue
these things together.
This is the Webpack entry point.
I just use Node style require
statements to pull in the Dart
SDK and the main app.
The Dart SDK is just used to
actually set some cool tools
in the debugger and
dev tools in Chrome.
I'll get back to
that in a moment.
But all this is really doing
is firing off the main entry
point in the application.
Of course, there's
this interesting bit
of code in the middle here.
Webpack has support for
hot module reloading.
DDC doesn't know anything
about hot module reloading.
But it doesn't actually need
to, because again, we're just
talking to the same modules.
So as soon as Webpack
sends out a signal,
I just have a listener
here that listens for it,
calls clear on my
Dart application,
does a require to
load the new version,
and just calls the
entry point on that.
So let's see this in action.
This is the Captain's Log app.
Firefox, Safari, Chrome, all
running at the same time.
Let's make some
interesting changes here.
So we've got these
stardates at the bottom.
This is the WYSIWYG
editor called Quill.
And Jacob will talk a little
bit about how that works.
You enter stuff in here.
It shows up in your log.
We have stardates.
These stardates look
awfully like Earth dates.
2016, that looks a
little suspicious.
So let's just make
a simple change.
I've conveniently put
this at the bottom.
I'll save it.
And we'll go back.
And you can see Earth date
shows up everywhere more or less
immediately.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: That might
have been too quick.
All right, notice how
there's a toolbar up here.
Turns out Quill has
different themes.
You can play around
with that, too.
So let's go here and
change from the snoot theme
to the bubble theme.
And we now have the
bubble theme here.
What happened to my toolbar?
Bubble uses tool tips.
So I can check that, hey, this
renders on all my browsers.
And again, it's just
reloading it on the fly.
We didn't actually have
to reset the state.
You can see I'm in the
middle of editing something.
If I reload it, the "This
is Chrome" part disappears.
But it's all just
happening live here.
So that's cool.
We get a lot of stuff for free
just by designing our system
modularly.
I didn't really spend
a whole lot of time
trying to get Webpack working.
It just happened to work.
So hopefully, we'll get
a lot of those features.
Let me show a little
bit about debugging.
So Webpack does
support Source Maps.
And it can handle the Source
Maps that DDC changes.
But I have to run it
in this debug mode.
That just makes things
like a half second slower,
so I found that
kind of annoying.
But let's start it up again.
The apps are reloading here.
You can see the text that
I had written is all gone.
But we're now live again.
And let's zoom
out here in Chrome
and start looking at
the dev tools here.
So I have a breakpoint.
Let's see if I've
actually saved it.
Yup.
So I set a breakpoint here.
And as you can see,
we're in Dart source.
This is captains_log.dart at
the breakpoint in the Dart code
itself, right?
And so even though
I'm in regular Chrome,
I get a pretty nice to
look at stack trace here.
So saveLog here is
the handler that
gets registered on the button.
And we stopped here in
a [INAUDIBLE] log which
is getting called from that.
And what's kind of
cool here is that we
have hooks in the dev tools,
which Dan talked about earlier.
So when you actually
hover over log entries,
you actually see the Dart type.
It's a JS linked hash map.
And you see the reified
type information.
So we're keeping all
of that in there.
We're using it and enforcing
it, the safety of it.
And the nice thing
is when you are
developing, when you're bugging,
you see that type information.
And you also see a nice,
Darty view of the hash map.
You get the double
keys and the values.
And you can even
drill down on that
and expand and look at the
div itself, if you wanted.
So you get a nice
dev tools experience
because we're saving
all this information
and displaying it to
you in a nice way.
One final thing I
just want to show here
is when we do the
hot update, what
actually is happening here?
So let's go back and actually
change that thing back
to snow, which I
like better anyway.
And we'll see that it
gets slightly slower.
But it gets reloaded.
And these two things
come down the pipe.
And it's just a message that's
showing some information.
And it's only sending the
minimal thing down, right?
It's not resending the Dart
SDK or any other packages.
It's just generating--
I edited Captain's Log.
I'm getting captains_log.js
down the pipe.
This gives us a good chance
to take a look at JavaScript.
So we can see that this code got
generated with the snow theme.
And that was
effectively the update.
So you know, it sent
the whole package.
I guess it could have
had a smarter diff,
but I don't really know a whole
lot about how Webpack works.
That's kind of the point of
the demo actually, right?
So just to show an example
of what the code looks like,
though, it's not perfectly
idiomatic Dart code.
But it's pretty readable.
So for example,
calculate stardate
is clearly a function
with the name that
matches the original Dart name.
We're calling into the core
library to create a date time,
a couple date times
with different arguments
and different constructors,
as you can see.
We're calling the
difference method.
We're doing add.
You can notice this is
one case where we actually
have to do some runtime
checking in DDC.
We don't know from
the type system
yet that we have a
non-nullable number here.
So we have to do a null check.
Of course, if the type
system told us these things,
we'd get better code.
So we're always asking
for that kind of stuff.
In this case, we happen to know
that this is a private member
to the package.
So we know that that
one is not nullable.
So we don't have to check that.
But in general, we love
things in the type system.
So let's see.
That's the demo.
Again, this was something
I quickly put together.
All the code is
up here in GitHub.
All the code is there.
I promise to actually put
instructions in the next couple
days before the summit
is done if anyone's
interested in actually
reproducing this.
So I mentioned I just spent like
a day or so hacking up Webpack
just to show that it worked.
We've been very much
focused in the past year
internally with DDC.
And there's a good
reason for that, right?
First of all, we
have all these teams
that are basically paying us.
So we gotta do that.
But we also wanted to prove that
anything we do works at scale.
We need to scale to many,
many megabytes of code
to run our internal
applications,
to provide a good
developer experience
for these applications.
And we wanted to prove it
there, right, at size of code,
at a complex set of
web dependencies.
And we felt that if we
could prove it here, then
we could take it to the small,
like I did with Webpack,
and get things to
work pretty quickly
and get our assumptions right.
So part of the
complexity here is just
all of these dependencies.
We have the Dart SDK.
We have all kinds
of packages in pub.
We have Angular Dart,
which you saw about today.
We have all these cool
Angular Dart components
which you saw earlier today.
We had a lot of common internal
infrastructure, some of it
UI, some of it other stuff.
We have components on
our own application.
An application author will
have their own components.
And they'll have
a main app again
that weaves this all together.
It's also not just Dart code.
[? Farhat and Matan ?] talked
about this a little bit today.
But Angular templates, they
have a generation process
to turn those templates
into Dart code.
We have things like
protocol buffers
that we use for
serialization where
you can change specifications.
And it generates Dart code.
And all of these are part of
our build framework, right?
And the thing we've
been focusing on
is making this work in Bazel.
And you'll hear more
about that tomorrow.
But Bazel gives you parallelism.
It gives you caching.
It's really a great
tool to build large apps
at scalability and speed.
And I can't show the app itself.
It's an internal app.
But just going to walk you
through the life of an edit.
Let's suppose we're editing
one of our components.
Most of our app authors
are not necessarily here,
but they're often here.
They're usually not
all the way down here.
And we want to make the
incremental build process work
really well for them.
So let's suppose we're editing
one of our own table components
inside of our app.
It's an Angular component.
So step one here is to actually
generate from the templates,
take Dart and HTML
templates, and produce Dart.
And in this
particular case, that
took about 200 milliseconds.
Now the Dart library, so step
two in this build process,
this is basically kicked off
as soon as you do an edit,
is to build the summary.
And that takes about, in
this case, a little bit
less than 300 milliseconds.
Step three is to actually build
a JavaScript corresponding
to this component.
But we don't have to
wait for the summary.
As soon as we have
the Dart library,
we start kicking that off
in parallel right there.
The summary, like I mentioned,
you saw this in the make file,
is used to inform
downscale dependencies.
So if we have
downstream dependencies,
if we have something
using table,
we use the summary
to type check it.
And in this case,
the summary, the edit
happened to change the summary.
So I have to build another
component library that
depends on that table.
So for this change, I had
some cascading dependencies.
I build that summary.
Again, you can show-- this is
basically a time line here.
So this is actually
happening while I'm
doing DDC on another thread.
I can also start compiling
that new component that
happens to be a fairly big one.
So it took a little bit of time.
And then finally, I had a main
app that I needed to compile,
too.
And the cool thing about
this particular example
is I have three different
things compiling.
But at some point
in time, they're
all happening in parallel.
So I'm taking advantage of the
parallelism on my workstation.
And if I want to
do this at scale,
well, Google has a
nice infrastructure
for parallel builds.
And then finally, when
all these things are done,
I just bundle it up.
And I'm done.
And this whole thing took
a little bit over a second.
So that's the kind
of experience that we
can get when you do this
at a much larger scale.
Many changes are local.
So if I was doing a local
change that didn't cascade out
of the table component,
I'd basically
be done at this point right
here and able to bundle it.
So in that kind of
more common case,
this would take more
like half a second.
So to summarize, what
do you get from DDC?
You get a fast, modular rebuild.
You get readable ES6 code.
You get nice,
iterative development
on multiple browsers.
And we've done a lot of
extra work in Chrome,
dev tools support with Chrome.
And Jacob promised, if
I left him extra time,
he'll actually do a demo that'll
show even cooler things than I
was able to get into.
As Leif talked about,
soundness in strong mode.
DDC works very nicely
with strong mode.
It requires strong mode, but
it exploits it quite nicely.
The status, it's still
kind of in a beta state.
But we are-- it is actually
being used by several teams
internally for their
day to day development.
As I mentioned, our
initial focus is Chrome.
But we are now in the Dart SDK.
We used to be in a
different GitHub location.
We've moved.
You can find our code over here,
as Kevin mentioned, or Bob.
We are the DartDevC
binary now in the SDK
as of somewhat recently.
And we still have
the mailing list.
You can chime in with questions
and hopefully get some answers.
But that's basically
what we got.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]